[Music]
Madonna's doing just fine on Monday the
Material Girl clapped back at critics
with a photo of herself on Twitter which
she captioned look how cute I am now
that swelling from surgery has gone down
LOL the Tweet appeared to reference
Madonna's appearance at the 2023 Grammy
Awards earlier this month where she
introduced Sam Smith and Kim Petrus to
the stage
the moment however was overshadowed by
some viewers taking aim at her looks and
questioning if she had surgery days
later the global Superstar addressed the
criticism on Instagram writing once
again I am caught in the glare of ageism
and misogyny that permeates the world we
live in a world that refuses to
celebrate women past the age of 45. she
continued I look forward to many more
years of subversive Behavior pushing
boundaries standing up to the patriarchy
and most of all enjoying my life